Max sitzt fest Quarantäne er hat sich
mit Omicron infiziert
Schnupfen Hustenreiz und leichtes
Krankheitsgefühl Müdigkeit auch also
Mann war ein bisschen träge ist die
Delta Variante oder handelt es sich
tatsächlich um onikon diese Frage treibt
ihn um
jemand vom Gesundheitsamt um Viren
abzuholen und dann gezüchtet werden denn
nur eine Genomanalyse kann dies klären
nach 9 Tagen steht fest es ist Omegon
zwischen wieder besser geht ist Max denn
noch beunruhigt
zu denen ich Kontakt hatte
keiner ist hat er Symptome oder ist
positiv getestet worden also ich habe da
im Dunkeln wenige Wochen zuvor am 4.
November war und Nikon erstmals in
Südafrika bemerkt worden die neue Virus
Variante gibt den Wissenschaftlern
Rätsel auf viel weiß man noch nicht und
jeden Tag gibt es neue Erkenntnisse
tatsache ist dass diese Variante hoch
ansteckend ist und sich rasend schnell
verbreitet mittlerweile wurde sie auf
allen Kontinenten festgestellt
[Musik]
hab keinen Fall zur Vorsicht es ist so
dass wir jetzt bereits in England die
ersten hospitalisierten Fälle haben also
Patienten die wegen Omikron
im Krankenhaus behandelt werden müssen
gibt leider auch die ersten Berichte von
Todesfällen auf der Basis einer omnicron
Infektion
breitet sich aus
und 70 000 Menschen infizieren sich mit
der Variante
von einer regelrechten
Flutwelle ist die Rede die Sorge dass
die hochansteckende Variante das
infektions geschehen dominiert ist groß
für die schnelle Ausbreitung könnte es
mehrere Gründe geben erst spät wurde mit
dem Impfen von Kindern und Jugendlichen
begonnen
und das Virus macht offensichtlich
keinen halt auch nicht vorgelesen oder
geimpften laut einer aktuellen Studie
sollen selbst 2 fach Impfungen nur wenig
Schutz dagegen bieten umso wichtiger bei
das posten sollte nicht warten das sage
ich auch als bezieht auf einen
modifizierten Impfstoff was Omicron
angeht dieser wird voraussichtlich erst
im April zur Verfügung stehen und dann
ist es zu spät also klare Botschaft
jetzte boosten lassen um sich auch vor
Omikron schützen zu lassen und das geht
nicht nur für reiserückkehrer denn
längst sind auch hierzulande Menschen
mit onikon infiziert die keinerlei
Kontakt zu Südafrika hatten wir sind mit
Omicron sehr vorsichtig weil wir wissen
dass dies die große Herausforderung der
nächsten Wochen und Monate ist in es
gibt in Bayern den ersten Fall eine
Hospitalisierung inzwischen auch aber
dort sie Gott sei Dank im Moment die
Verläufe mild des Patienten der also im
Krankenhaus ist zurück der 27-Jährige
sich infiziert aber
nichtsdestotrotz
wenn ich nicht wäre wärst nicht nur eine
leichte Erkältung gewesen seine
Quarantäne im Hotelzimmer ist ihm nicht
vorbei die gesamten Kosten dafür
übernimmt der Stadt 14 Tage ohne
jeglichen persönlichen Kontakt zur
Außenwelt keine Familie keine Freunde
das Essen vor die Tür gesetzt
ich versuche positiv